all right good to see derrick in studio
our neighborhood shout out tonight you
guys ready for this
we're bringing back the neighborhood
shout outs andrea moses
from centennial hills hi drea hi thanks
for watching us here
and we're back to normal we got
everybody back at the desk too and we're
bringing that neighborhood shout out but
i was saying my my hand's pretty
too big for this your boutonniere is
pretty
yeah i guess pretty generous too those
are really those are really my legs you
just gave yourself a fist-popper yeah
there we go there you go what's florendo
all right the same forecast let's get to
it all right here we go
satellite radar outside right now we are
getting some showers to the north in
lincoln county yeah you're getting some
of those
light showers are moving their way
southward though and look at that the
clouds are there
but then they dissipate as they start to
hit some of our drier air
and what we get when that happens is
this and this is what we showed you
yesterday i was telling some of my
neighbors
neighbors yesterday when we were out
that a lot of the rain wasn't going to
reach the ground and it just
just dissipated and turned into gusty
winds alright evaporated
now some of you in the south did get
some showers
and good to see that but not all areas
got that rainfall so we picked up one
hundredth of an inch yesterday
officially that puts us at one
hundredths for the month but we should
be at five hundredths of an inch that's
normal for this time
in may currently outside 86 for
centennial hills summerlin 82 84 for the
lakes
88 downtown the east side 89 for sunrise
manor
green valley same for you along with
whitney ranch 87 for henderson
85 for rhodes ranch and mountain zed
southern highlands right now
at 87. 84 for a prompt indian spring 78
degrees remember you just had that
shower i was just pinpointing out to you
that's cooled things off quite a bit
that's why yesterday
a lot of neighborhoods were only in the
60s in the afternoon 87 for mesquite
93 for laughlin right now there's the
low around the slow
is the the shower activity behind it
okay this is the back side of the low
and eventually it's going to move its
way out of here tomorrow that's why all
that shower activity is going to
decrease from west to east
as we get through tonight winds for
tomorrow not too bad an elevated
elevated winds light breeze expected for
tomorrow the strongest winds will come
on thursday
even though we'll see the impacts of
those winds as early as
wednesday with those gusts up to 35.
tonight 69 degrees isolated shower
thunderstorm not out of the possibility
96 for tomorrow warmer and drier for
tomorrow
here's your most accurate extended eight
day forecast now look at that dropping
to 77 on friday
next week still no 100's in the 8 day
forecast denise back to you